what do you think about tanking Garcia  oh uh who would win  I hope I like Ryan Garcia yeah he's cool  I played poker with him before a couple  times nice I think once something like  that once or twice who would you take  uh man I don't I don't know Tang man but  I feel like he's just the Beast yeah  he's also like the kind of guy that like  I don't know man some of these boxes  he's a he's like a [ __ ] he's like a  you know he might as well be a part of  YSL the way he'd be [ __ ] acting I  like that [ __ ] I'm like bro you gotta  chill out bro you're a [ __ ]  professional athlete dawg like you can't  just be threatening people who want to  be entertained man I like that [ __ ] I'm  like dog you're gonna get they gonna put  a RICO on you bro chill out this  [ __ ] beefing with every rapper  alive for real oh my God why are you  beefing with rappers yeah people want to  be entertained man people like that [ __ ]  no he's dope